you know interesting Aussie story
um I remember when I started playing
with Ozzy this would have been 1996
we're in Las Vegas it was my second gig
and a song would have been Sweet Leaf
and we just went into that Groove you
know down down
under down all of a sudden Ozzy gets in
my face then we're like doing this dance
and it's like we're sumo wrestlers and
then it turns into this body position
we're going lower and lower and lower
next thing you know we are literally
like our booties are a foot off the
ground and we're doing what I call the
crab walk this moment for me was special
because this is a performance move that
I've been doing up until this day and I
enjoyed doing it sometimes Kirk and I do
it during For Whom the Bell Tolls so
thank you Ozzy thanks for providing me
your choreographed Ingenuity and helping
me uh turn on my stage performance with
the crab walk I appreciate you for that
foreign